i have a complaint to file with you
which is you have a very funny
uh show called hiking with kevin
where you get celebrity pals to hike
with you
i did it a while ago it must have been
what a year year and a half ago
it was about two years ago now
you're a year and a half anyway if
you're gonna file a complaint you're
gonna have to get the accurate date
all right well but let me just tell you
what the complaint is okay i did your
show
and just before i went out the door i
just grabbed a hat
i don't even think it was my hat it
might have been my wife's hat i don't
know whose hat it was i grabbed it and
put it on my head
and it looked terrible take a look let's
show people right now there it is
okay you didn't stop me you didn't say
anything
you didn't say hey conan that hat looks
stupid
you let me go out the door and then you
filmed me for your show
and it's been online and i'm taking a
lot of [ __ ] for that hat
why didn't you say something you're my
friend look
we're at a point in our friendship now
where you know you
i've always thought you did weird things
strange things i haven't always agreed
with your decisions or choices
so when i saw the hat i thought okay
he's making his bed he's going to sleep
in it
and it's a and a lot of people i mean i
have thousands of followers
have seen that you didn't realize how
popular my show was i didn't realize no
i didn't realize 100 people yeah
yeah and it wasn't a good look for me it
was not a good look but you went with it
and you you believed it you know they
sold a lot of those hats after that hike
i don't know they saw i actually uh
heard this from the manufacturer of that
hat
they saw a 100 increase in sales
because uh previously they had only sold
one
and then they sold another one yeah but
i think you know what
you you kind of generated a style with
that hat
it was kind of like a tom sawyer kind of
a look yeah
i looked sort of like a tom sawyer if he
had leukemia
uh not that good
nice nice nice slam good slam